à quelques instants les cubains
s'apprête à commémorer le trentième
anniversaire de la mort du symbole de la
révolution cubaine des années 50
le che guevara son compagnon fidel
castro au pouvoir depuis près de 40 ans
n'entend toujours pas renoncé au
socialisme même s'il parle aujourd'hui à
l'occasion du congrès du pc cubain de
socialisme de marché en fait depuis la
fin de l'union soviétique le dollar
effectué un retour en force sur l'île où
les 11 millions d'habitants sont privés
de tout ou presque
thierry thulliez jean françois rouleau
on passe devant sa boutique sans même
jeter un regard et la vendeuse reste au
sol coincé entre son comptoir et ses
rayons vides ou presque le seul
événement de la journée c'est l'arrivée
du livre il y à là quelques compote pour
les enfants du quartier
possède pour 15 jours
ou alors 14 pour un mois c'est pour les
enfants inscrits dans le quartier les
cubains ne font plus la queue depuis
longtemps devant ses magasins d'état où
on achète tout c'est à dire pas grand
chose avec des tickets de rationnement
diana ne couvre pas ses fruits dans ses
boutiques
mais sur des marchés privés dentiste
elle gagne l'équivalent de 100 francs
par mois un salaire correct à cuba elle
vit avec ses parents son mari et son
fils dans un petit trois pièces à l'avs
depuis trois ans pour l'alimentation ça
va mieux même si les prix sont élevés
avec ce nouveau marché on trouve des
produits qu'il n'y avait pas à moi
et c'est vrai que les étals sont plaints
dans ce marché les agriculteurs vendent
leurs propres produits aux prix fixés
par l'état
ça fait trois ans maintenant que ce
commerce est possible et ça a été une
mini révolution
mais s'il n'y a plus de pénurie diana ne
mangent toujours pas à sa faim beaucoup
de choses sont très très cher c'est tout
mon célèbre jeu dépenses en nourriture
presque tous bien sûr ici ou là je peux
acheter autre chose
mais l'alimentation c'est l'essentiel
diana ne se rend presque jamais dans les
ruelles de la vieille havane
ici commence un autre territoire que
seuls les cubains qui ont affaire aux
touristes fréquentent
les meilleures tables dans les meilleurs
restaurants tout est permis aux
étrangers de passage
le tourisme est devenu la première
source de l'ue et celui qui a donné de
l'air à l'économie cubaine étrange
paradoxe dans le pays de fidel castro le
dollar roi s'impose désormais à tous